Hales gonna browse monies pierpass and
welcome to heart of darkness
yes yes let's play
I really want to watch it this is an old
classic a friend suggested it to me I'm
really excited to do an old-school game
that I haven't actually played and yeah
should be fun
should be I hope it lays everybody's
shitty [ __ ] serious
what is this so try to make it seem like
a movie executive producer main team oh
god I hear a little bit of weird frame
dropping I'm emulating this but I
brought the game sure it's okay
that's probably why but I it works fine
later what is this [ __ ] 90s film what
am I looking at
we're playing a game heart of darkness
holy [ __ ]
this is so strange
oh my god beautiful Oh
let's watch a movie with pair 2pi
fascinating
I
no just sleeping
oh god that's terrifying no way Jose
yeah I'm gonna use that one oh holy [ __ ]
that's a gem
oh they're matching their colors that's
adorable look everyone it's Edgar what a
piece of [ __ ] yeah radical [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah when I'm in San Francisco holy
[ __ ] they're crazy Oh cow
what the [ __ ] is this I did not expect
watching the [ __ ] Toy Story I don't
even know what am i watching and why
you see a boy or a girl I can't town not
that there's anything wrong holy [ __ ] a
solar eclipse Wow that's a one Wilson
standard at Wow Wow
oh my god solar eclipse I don't know
where oh it sucked up my dog oh man why
don't that happen to me that'd be so
awesome
everyone be like hey what happened' Gabi
like I was solar eclipse nothing to do
about it
Oh grow up your [ __ ] new t-shirt is way
too short man no one shows their navel
if your navel is showing get the [ __ ]
out going how did it get that vault door
up there get out of here
holy [ __ ] he has a great ass I'm sorry I
just noticed it I can't be the only one
to thought about it DEFCON 2
okay up that's how you mash me brofist
to that [ __ ] Oh No activate you should
hide me I'm voice acting this [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] I do not expect a [ __ ] movie
Apple how about you pack your own bag
[ __ ] sorry I'm sorry
holy [ __ ] we have a flying car
of course let's not forget about the gun
was that a spaghetti hose that's a hat
good just checking
I have so many [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
going on uh maybe you should be worrying
about the wall [ __ ] hell it's like
when Conan was playing Jesus Christ
we have an AI someone just spit on my
street
I love our oldish the comments are like
what the [ __ ] is this game pants I don't
know I've never played it please take
off the Hat please get a haircut get a
job nd here we go that was the intro
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] alright the heart of
darkness demo I don't know why it says
demo wait what the what the [ __ ] what
the what the what what did I just watch
your [ __ ] demo for 13 minutes oh okay
that's that's cool here we go yeah okay
I can move I think
whew oh [ __ ] so this game was very
revolutionary for its time with all the
cutscenes you see it's runs a lot
smoother now it was I mean it runs okay
alright but the game I totally forgot I
was gonna say but we have this gun look
at the graphics holy [ __ ] this is like a
laser whip it's pretty cool it's really
beautiful
Oh God oh alright I take that back I
take that back
Jesus Christ
okay so there's a lot of weeks you can
die this game and we just found one of
them there we go that's we properly did
it okay what is that
Oh God nope uh no thanks I can't stop
singing in his ass there guys should I'm
children should have here we go we're
fine
Jason god damnit deaf count number two
thank you thank you for people keeping
count so you got to watch out for the
shadows I guess I shoot this [ __ ]
thing there we can can i oh god I'm
scared
hey we did it pres [ __ ] are you
kidding man stop you go away you go away
holy chicken in double-jump biscuit okay
alright we're gonna take it slow now
just shoot everything all right careful
careful there we go oh god no yeah get
off me now
ah ah hey sup humph he's [ __ ] me yeah
yeah just shoot your ass Sep jumping
pieces ah piss me off
Oh woah woah woah what the [ __ ] does
happen okay there's a million of them
there's literally act get up we car I'm
so stressed out I'm so stressed out what
is going on I'm literally mass murder
this is genocide I'm worse than Hitler
Oh God they keep coming I'm just gonna
go I'm just gonna go oh god they're so
annoying sorry Oh bah oh god damn it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] ah
are you kidding me
please what do I do
ah oh god they're eating me [ __ ] what do
i do what am i oh what's that
what that's brutal I'm still a kid guys
this is like in 90s the best days where
you could kill kids
best best times this is a [ __ ] up all
right [ __ ] up all right all right
[ __ ] off right get yo you're pissing me
off to piss man no no Jesus right they
never stop no what do I do
surely I need to shoot something else oh
it's the clay it's great go whoa Jay
says it starts up so hard like calm down
game I know you're old and [ __ ] but [ __ ]
me all right
I mean please don't Jesus paisa Leary
hey I'm scared of describing them
because it would be where Rachel and I
don't want it to be I don't know they
need a name uh black son of a [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] that's me
[ __ ] I don't know I'm just gonna ah this
game is our dance Jesus Christ
I'll be back here I'm like don't call
your friends please don't call my
friends
No No
like oh my god oh my god oh my god
holy [ __ ] this is ridiculous wedding
this is the game that looks like [ __ ]
eight-year-olds would play and I'm
sucking so much at it is there a better
way to do it
thank you thank you I really appreciate
everyone counting my desk really
supportive there I really appreciate it
[ __ ] off there it is
hey the [ __ ] jumped over me I hate when
[ __ ] jump over me no no no no no no
no no no go yeah oh my god [ __ ] ah give
me a goddamn No ah ah Dyer son of a
[ __ ] Jax
ah you [ __ ] my dog get off oh no no no
aah
please oh okay okay keep going keep
going
no no no no no yo oh my god no no no no
no no okay we're here fine oh [ __ ] god
damn it oh my god
are you Aaron s how did had it but don't
give me hit don't patronize me
[ __ ] oh oh let's jump over them got
it
ha [ __ ] you alright [ __ ] you alright
wait you can't jump faster you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay jump there it is uh oh god I gotta
go go go go go go go so creepy [ __ ] off
oh god damn it just gonna shake shake
shake
yeah and they [ __ ] me awesome just just
great you know what I don't care how
great the dog is [ __ ] him [ __ ] the dog
alright
Jesus oh [ __ ] listen I'd be I'd not even
what I would not even watch the cutscene
to save the Edgar's ass alright Jesus
Christ can we just chill
can we just get like a little break can
we just like calm down a little bit oh
god I'm just alright it's cold so glad
I'm live streaming this this is great
quality game ah da [ __ ] off man [ __ ]
just [ __ ] off okay here we go alright
there we go
no don't touch me all right Jesus Christ
that's son of a [ __ ] stop tripping me
Oh God I can climb it [ __ ] ah okay ah
[ __ ] that's right burn in hell burn in
hell where you came from can we go back
to school now alright I'm gonna guess
that the story is that we're still in
the closet and we're just scared of the
dark that's what I'm gonna call God oh
look it's it's Kim's mom hey give back
my spaghetti hat holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] my
god well then oh great and just oh stop
rage just desperation yes
get-get steak awesome oh my god that was
literally the sound from South for
having direct part the Raptors I mean
but I'd still hit it just if to say that
yeah I do it um all right what do I do
here
Oh awesome awesome just just [ __ ] hell
can we just chill the [ __ ] out how do
you play this as a kid I've been scarred
for life my god I just keep getting
eaten every [ __ ] second okay I think
I get it I think I need to jump and
dodge got it oh great I'll just fake
what a great tackle what a great tactic
they just Instagram me how about you
guys stop counting the [ __ ] deaf and
help me out Jesus Christ
jump down how do I jump down I don't
think I can do that
oh my god don't jump in his mouth
go go go go go go go yeah what am i
doing I love what no one knows about
this game so it's like oh well hello
then I'm just gonna go Oh awesome
how long did it take how long did it
take to find another [ __ ] Jesus
Christ okay so run and then walk
carefully
okay Oh awesome that's cool okay it's
very cool game I'm surprised like I
haven't seen many more games like this
one it's very unique
like [ __ ] got me didn't he panicking
panicking panic
[ __ ] god damn it
oh man this is painful it's fun though
I don't know it's cool okay so yep I'm a
mess el Vettes Jabba he wants my ass so
bad I mean I can relate go go go go oh
my god holy [ __ ] that was awesome hey
you wanted this baby
you want a disc but what am i doing
[ __ ] ceiling you're one of my - you
wanted it an ass that's right baby
can't have it can't have it yeah radda
radda Oh God
the [ __ ] is that
let's go up here alright let's see how
long we can go with that dang be cool a
few seconds or something like that that
I'd be pretty impressed if that happens
look hey I'm fine thanks game thanks for
not killing me appreciate it oh my god
alright we got to go up here
oh okay you had to press again to grab
oh are you kidding me
god [ __ ] you game that was the [ __ ]
worst oh my god um okay great
this is going great um all right here we
go ha did it now let's drop down here
thanks
let's not [ __ ] fall up again here we
go I think we got to do the same thing
here no there we go another one another
one camera dare a brush come on three
two one
uh I'm scared I'm too scared I can't do
it
[ __ ] this Edgar's not worth day ok fine
yep yeah holy [ __ ] I'm a parkour boss
alright
this is cool oh no don't I want my gun
back though should I grab on to there oh
my god that'd be epic this is like that
movie got to do some push-ups that's
some is that push-ups yes sure this is
something charging it charging it charge
in it
awesome all right so come on buddy
helmet yeah feet cocky rather than fun
oh this is like pew duck pie I swear to
god it's so hard this is really what
when games were hard or maybe I'm just
bad probably a combination of the two he
doesn't move no no they [ __ ] put that
[ __ ] there just to [ __ ] okay to reach an
exit I know that I don't know
jabba Lafitte that all right yeah you
see him clearly go up there so that's
where we're gonna go
the rope I doubt we can grab that [ __ ]
the rope what oh my god oh oh
mind blown ah what are you kidding me
date how do how would you know that how
would you know that
oh my god Jesus Christ are you kidding
me that is their most random [ __ ]
thing
double jump doubled really those [ __ ]
oh boy
I'm legit pissed now okay fine
see if I care oh god that's creepy as
hell
Oh remember honey fun no oh oh thank god
oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm just gonna go
yeah that did the trick didn't it yeah
what oh boy nope uh-huh how many boy at
I haven't even waves can you kill a boy
alright thank you thank you very much um
alright another troll [ __ ] troll game
mm why isn't he grabbing there we go oh
oh great hey we got a bridge now cool
who made this game I'm really curious
about it
whew cutscene
okay cool innovative Oh
the graphics are worse in the cutscene
no I can see that ass never mind
woah holy [ __ ] what is that that's
redundant trump lives
can we use another wall oh that's hot
this is where they brought Edgar that
guy came from someone's [ __ ]
Jesus is getting intense man
this is so super radical this is a myth
balls the presence of your own darkness
but you know how much I enjoy sleeping
for you I know the money's never great
but I've managed to find you the perfect
promise me
like I look super evil tipping [ __ ] I
want to jerk off his nose
Oh Oh No the boys in your kingdom holy
[ __ ] that's awesome this game is so cool
I really like it
alright press I'm sorry but we're gonna
have to end that episode there if you
enjoyed please leave a like it really
supports the series and I love doing
these kind of longer brushes for your
brows so thank you and as always stay
awesome breasts how God is crying you
salty salty tears napstablook is wishing
they weren't here alright I'm sure we
can make a move out